yo speaking of what you see young thug
gets slip to perk while in prison I
think he got set up with that no there's
no way I think his
friend co-defendant is just that big of
an idiot
I mean like insane they know you suffer
like he's going through withdrawal so oh
yeah how long does withdrawal last I
mean he's probably still getting it yeah
at the end of the day he's still young
at that yeah right and he's probably in
holding in some like yeah like jail or
something that's so easy to get drugs in
there they're all doing drugs if you
want it but if anyone didn't see the
video that's basically it so codependent
pulls up they're like taking a recess or
a break in the courtroom
and it's just so obvious like
here here you go bailiff walks up and
just like what are you doing yeah no
like I don't get why he thought that was
gonna fly
gets immediately caught
he goes and grabs the other guy and then
yo is this Young Thug's fault I think
you can only punish
the co-defendant here because there's no
proof that young thug asks for the perk
he just gave a five to his boy and his
boy put something in his hand that's
what his lawyer said immediately yeah
yeah oh I didn't he didn't ask for this
he thought he was just saying hello Yeah
he doesn't do drugs he didn't even know
what he gave them yeah yeah so I don't
think it's gonna necessarily reflect on
him but his code defense is going to get
screwed yeah well let me ask you this
maybe this is a dumb question if you're
whole if people accuse you of being like
the head of a gang and you're like no
I'm not and then a guy walks up to you
and hands you drugs as like the boss
doesn't that in some way it's
circumstantial but yeah am I am I not
looking on as a juror like that
[__] is the head of a gang maybe
I think you can get out of that like how
many people do perks that aren't that of
a game you know what I mean yeah and
also like how many people in jail are
doing some form of drugs no it's not
about doing the drugs it's about the guy
walking up to you in court and handing
it to you like yeah I mean I guess you
could be friends and not be yeah like I
understand like that's the type of power
that you could make somebody do some
something that's stupid
that's the kind of yeah if you're that
powerful someone would that risky is the
best word I think someone would take
that risk of like I'm gonna slide them
I'll Curry favor with him I'll get in a
good side whatever and to me I'd start
looking at him like you might be the
head of a gang yeah because no friend is
doing that for another friend I don't
think anybody at this point also
disputes whether he is the head of a
gang right like that's what they've been
I mean they've been claiming it in music
for [__] ever so it's like I
understand you can't use the music to
prove it but I'm not I don't think
there's any issue whether he's the head
of the gang I think now it's like are
you gonna hit them with the RICO or are
you gonna say that
he actually called the shots and then
the people died right because I think
the RICO you could hit him but it's not
going to be as long as actual murder
yeah so
it's not looking good for Doug it ain't
right is he about to take the whole
thing for everybody I wonder what I
don't get what their defense is because
it's like it he still hasn't spoken out
to say whether or not
he's okay with all the other people make
uh
taking a plea so it's like until he
speaks out like we don't know whether or
not like
he wants this to happen or not like uh
he might just be taking the whole thing
what if they said this to him
what they said y'all you're gonna get
the same time no matter what
I'm gonna give a hypothetical you tell
me if it's ridiculous
what if they said look you're gonna get
the same time no matter what whether
gonna and the other guys are are
involved in this case or not if you are
found guilty you're going to get the
same time
if these guys play out they the way that
their pleas are structured is they're
not going to use their testimony against
you they're not going to be brought back
into to testify nothing they're just
playing out I think is the case right
yeah yeah it's current I believe it's
something like that took a plea but part
of the plea agreement was that they had
to admit that they were a part of the
gang and they were involved in some
nefarious activities right
so but nothing involving that no okay
okay so what if the dude is like look
all these guys you can't get off
nobody's offering you a plea you're the
[__] OG like there's no offer for you
every one of your boys has an offer and
it doesn't really hurt you if they take
that offer
it doesn't change your chances
what you can do is get all your people
off and it doesn't incriminate you in
any way and it does or any more than
you're already incriminated and you
still have the same 50 50 chance of
beating this or 70 30 chance of being
this Etc one of him as an OG just goes
tell them [__] to get off that
could be the case but yeah I can't say
that now because
then the prosecutors will look at it
like oh word okay now we're gonna throw
the bug at you hmm that could be it
because it is weird that he hasn't said
anything and he knows that his silence
is hurting Gunner right now yeah by him
staying silent like everybody's debating
whether Gunner's a snitch or not exactly
and the lean and heavily toward the is
side yeah 100 people I'm following him
the whole thing like because what he did
is snitching it's exactly but if he's
basically told like yo you got a 70 30
chance like 70 guilty 30 not guilty and
it's just like and and that's not going
to change if these [__] get out
and your time ain't going to change if
these [__] get out
they get out there hold down your family
they can do XYZ I I just I just wonder
and if that 30 if he gets out if he gets
off from this if it's the 30 works out
for whatever [__] reason
and then he gets out like he is
the OG of OG oh that's why I feel like
you took care of all your boys yeah and
and you get to say nah they were gonna
ride with me and I said no go out there
and hit the streets this is the
responsibility of being a [__] OG the
Capo or not the capital the the Don or
whatever it is then all them are Street
qualified again because they just did
what the top dog told them to do
the crew is the biggest crew in [__]
rap because they beat the charges
I'm maybe he's looking at almost on some
like I gotta roll the dice and then I'm
the top dog yeah because if they get off
on this who's bigger
and rap on some Street [__] does him
does gun of snitching not affect him at
all if he's told to snitch by Thug I
don't think it is and Thug comes out and
says we told him to do it and it was how
we played the case and so what uh and
everybody of course no one really knows
all the details but there were certain
things that he said during The Plea
where it was just like oh were you in
the car with young thug while this this
crime happened and he said yes so people
like hey you're snitching on Thug but
then I heard that they can't use
anything said in the plea agreement
um they can't force those people to
testify for anything that was said in
the plea agreement so even if they call
Gunner to the stand for the Thug's trial
he can just plead the fit because he'd
be incriminating himself as he admits
everything so if they all just plead the
fifth then
I don't know what case the prosecution
has except the stuff that they have like
hard evidence and but I don't get why
the DIA is just like giving everyone
plea deals to not try to like it
normally if you give someone a plea deal
you're trying to use them to get someone
that's what I don't understand too so I
don't get why the D.A isn't like it
would look so good for them to say hey
we got all these gangsters off the
street all these criminals these guys
are killing people selling drugs and we
got all of them off the street they can
still say that look all of these people
admitted that this was a game
and that's That's the basis of the RICO
it's like hey he's the head of it all
these people confirm that this is a gang
so that's all my purpose or whatever
yeah it just that's what I'm saying this
is right but like if as long as the if
that's all they want is for them to
corroborate then it's a gang even if
they take the plea deal they're still
[__] gun or still [__] Thug over
because they're saying this again that
would be a pretty generous that's the
offer I think is what he's saying right
yeah that'd be a very generous plea deal
like if you're Atlanta and everybody
gets off it's so [__] embarrassing
for you no no no they're not getting off
when you take a plea that's a win for
the prosecution right because
you just don't have to but how long what
are they getting are they getting jail
time parole yeah I think parole for a
long time yeah yeah but it's like it's
still that's a win in the prosecution
time yeah that's an important thing how
you look at it you've got admission of
guilt yeah and you didn't have to go
through an expensive trial so like the
city or the state saves money and they
get to look at their record and be like
see we got all these thugs to go snitch
on their boy yeah because I was looking
quarter public opinion I would think you
know they I think court public opinion
you're right I don't think it looks like
they just got off it looks like Atlanta
is like [__] Madness kind of that's
what act was kind of saying here is that
crime is up everywhere and the easy
target is the guys that are saying they
can make crime on the record so let's
just go after them and but if they get
off now you're still looking at Atlanta
like you know Atlantic crime has gone up
and those guys are back on the street
you just can't look at it that way
because one they're not getting off two
now they're on probation so they're
going to be on their best behavior if
I'm the mayor so I'm not looking at it
I'm putting pressure on and I don't know
if this makes any difference I'm putting
pressure on for you to be lock these
[__] up I'm not thinking about
what you think is a win I'm thinking
about what gets me reelected and what
makes Atlanta looks better in the eyes
of the country
I'm not trying to let all these guys off
because oh they admitted it's a gang the
gang is free so what the [__] we gonna
do about it but then if they happen but
your job is all these cases individually
your job isn't sorry to interrupt you
but your job isn't motivated by what
makes Atlanta look better in the country
your job is motivated by conviction rate
yeah so we all at the end of the day
it's just like oh we got these people to
admit guilt now I get four more check
boxes over here and then when I go for
re-election or I have to go in front of
the mayor and say look what my
percentages are I got 80 they don't care
what La is but brought down this
criminal organization last piece of
pushback because I'm not super dug into
this position I'm playing Devil's
Advocate more so but if I'm voting for a
D.A I'm gonna go off my opinion and what
the public opinion is supposed to
conviction record right D.A is elected
right I thought D.A is um appointed by
the mayor no no no
I think it's elected if it's elected
then I'm not voting again
George foreign
also even if the mayor appointed you and
I'm the mayor I'd be like we'll get lock
these [__] up because I don't
care what your conviction rate is if we
look foolish if you make us look foolish
I'm replacing you um great Point too but
it just think about it if they had to
try all these cases then we're going to
be waiting years before you get
convictions and now it's like look you
locked all these people up not a single
conviction yet because of a way to like
Doug's trial probably won't be done
until my suspicion is this gonna there
wasn't much evidence to really pin gun
into anything real
yeah I think he was like around and I'm
sure a bunch of the other music guys
were like around people [__] with their
heads and be like yo we know we got on
you we got everything and your boy's
gonna snitch yeah that's the real [__]
yeah but maybe they were tight enough to
know that nobody was gonna [__]
snitch that's the thing luckily they
still have money so they got these
lawyers and I'm pretty sure all the
lawyers are in coats yeah I guess maybe
I mean we're gonna see what happens it
seems like some DA's are alike and some
are appointed I don't know I don't have
time to figure that out